from time to time viewers ask us
about record-breaking molecules the
biggest the heaviest the lightest the
smallest
i want to tell you about the heaviest
possible molecule that you can have with
five atoms that molecule
is organesson element 118
tetratenocide that is with four atoms of
tenocine
117
now this is purely a theoretical
exercise
because although people have made
atoms of organism and tenocine
they've never made the atoms at the same
time did you make
a ganeshan in this
reactor yes yes
but they're really two quite interesting
questions that you can tackle using
computation
the first question is
will organison actually react with
tenocine
xenon which is next to iodine in the
periodic table doesn't react
with
iodine so you can't get xenon tetra
iodide or at least
nobody's isolated it as well as i'm
aware so one question is if you could
make this molecule
would it be stable would there be bonds
actually between the atoms or would they
fall apart the second question which
chemists always ask is what shape would
the molecule be
could it be a tetrahedron that's with
four tenocines with the organessan in
the middle
could it be a square again with the
organess on in the middle but with the
four tennis scenes around it now
a recent paper tackles this problem
computationally
and their computations have two
different versions
one is a fairly straightforward
computation the other one considers
so-called relativistic effects
before we think about the calculations
few numbers
methane ch4 which is the lightest
stable
five atom molecule
weighs
16 units organess on
tetratenocide
would weigh
1470 units that's about 92 times heavier
so it's quite big if you add up all the
electrons
in this molecule they're 586
electrons
which is a lot and this is what makes
the computational
challenge so big
the other point is
when electrons travel very rapidly
and their speed approaches the speed of
light they get much heavier
this is a consequence of einstein's
relativity theories so
in the calculations
you can do two types of calculation one
type in which you ignore the relativity
and ignore the fact that the electrons
are traveling so fast around the nuclei
of the atoms and the other one in which
you include relativistic effects we had
a video some time ago explaining how
relativistic effects explain why the
element mercury is a liquid when most
other metals
are solids the upshot of these
calculations
is that without relativistic effects
organism tetratenocide
appears unstable
it wouldn't
easily bond together
with relativistic effects
it is stable not enormously but it could
form
and the fact that you can get a compound
of a organess on and tenocine
is really quite interesting what shape
is it
well
if you asked
inorganic chemists like me
they will say well
xenon tetrachloride
is
a square like this
so we'd expect organess on
tetratenocide
to have the same shape it turns out
that
these calculations suggest
that it would be tetrahedral that's not
the shape that we might expect you can
ask
is this all very important
doing a calculation
about a molecule which
is pretty unlikely ever to be made
and i would say yes it is important
because it is showing how one can refine
the
computational techniques to get
what we hope are better answers
now you might say
that's just martin's personal view
but
in this journal here
they have
2021's dramatic digits in chemistry and
down here is 586
the
number of electrons in
organism tetratenocide with a picture of
the molecule
we've done plenty more videos about
super heavy elements including trips to
russia the united states and germany
there'll be links on the screen at the
moment and also down in the video
description